[Música]
hola esto es áfrica siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano
bienvenidos comenzamos con los titulares
un respiro para malí los líderes de
áfrica occidental levantaron las
sanciones comerciales y financieras que
asfixiaban al país sumido en una crisis
política y de seguridad tras una semana
de debates en portugal finalizó la
conferencia de las naciones unidas sobre
los océanos nuestra enviada especial
marina colorado nos informa de las
demandas de los representantes africanos
y la copa de áfrica de fútbol femenino
comenzó en marruecos al final de esta
edición les ofrecemos un retrato de las
principales estrellas del continente
fue una cumbre muy esperada reunidos en
accra la capital de ghana a los
dirigentes de la comunidad económica de
estados de áfrica occidental cedeao
acordaron el levantamiento inmediato de
las sanciones económicas impuestas a
mali la decisión fue tomada en respuesta
a las promesas de la junta maliense de
organizar elecciones dentro de un plazo
de 24 meses la cedeao también expresó su
apoyo al compromiso mostrado por burkina
faso de restablecer el orden
constitucional en dos años
tolerancia cero a los golpes de estado o
concesiones ante este dilema los líderes
de áfrica occidental han optado por
evaluar caso por caso después de la ola
de golpes de estado que han afectado la
institucionalidad en la región para mal
y que sufrió un golpe de estado en 2020
el bloqueo comercial y financiero
establecido hace seis meses por parte de
la cedeao será levantado inmediatamente
a cambio de volver a un gobierno civil
en 2024 actos
descanso tras los debates los jefes de
estado tomaron las siguientes decisiones
de haydn
en primer lugar decidieron levantar
todas las sanciones económicas y
financieras que se adoptaron el 9 de
enero de 2022 contra malí jan
greenlining institute
y lo que significa esencialmente el
cierre de la frontera y la congelación
de los activos financieros estas
sanciones se levantan y sin embargo la
organización regional ha mantenido
sanciones individuales contra los
integrantes de la junta militar maliense
que se comprometió a llamar a elecciones
generales en dos años algo similar
sucede al estudiar los casos de burkina
faso y guinea países que también son
dirigidos por militares en el caso de
burkina faso país que enfrentó un golpe
de estado en enero de este año un
mediador de la cedeao parece haber
convencido al coronel paul henreid amiba
de que se da el poder a un presidente
elegido en un plazo de 24 meses a cambio
de que no sean decretada sanciones
económicas contra el país entretanto en
guinea el gobierno militar y el
organismo regional determinaron
mediadores que tendrán como primera
misión acelerar el calendario electoral
a pesar del levantamiento de las
sanciones y los acercamientos entre las
partes estos tres países de áfrica
occidental seguirán suspendidos de la
cedeao hasta que sean celebradas
elecciones generales y se restablezca el
orden crãtico
la onu se declaró conmocionada por la
tragedia de melilla en donde decenas de
inmigrantes murieron durante un intento
de cruzar la frontera entre marruecos y
españa el organismo internacional pidió
una investigación y denunció el uso
excesivo de la fuerza contra los
migrantes tanto por parte de la policía
marroquí como de la española
jets o funk listo estamos profundamente
consternados por la muerte de al menos
23 migrantes africanos y las lesiones de
al menos otros 76 cuando intentaban
cruzar de marruecos a españa el 24 de
junio
pedimos a ambos países que garanticen
que se lleve a cabo una investigación
efectiva e independiente como primer
paso para establecer las circunstancias
de estas muertes y lesiones y para
garantizar que se establezcan las
responsabilidades en su caso
el 28 de junio inmigrantes se
manifestaron frente a la oficina del
alto comisionado para los refugiados en
rabat la capital de marruecos
exigían que se identificaran los
cadáveres para poder informar a sus
familias
algunos reunieron el coraje para relatar
los hechos ante las cámaras
lo que ocurrió ese día fue que hubo un
empujón entre emigrantes que querían
cruzar al otro lado de melilla y la
policía intervino para golpearlos lo que
provocó la muerte de algunos de nuestros
hermanos hoy pedimos ver los cuerpos e
identificarlos para informar a sus
familias en sudán
fuimos a la ciudad de nador y nos
golpearon fuertemente el gobierno
marroquí dijo que hubo 23 muertos pero
sabemos que hay más de 70 muertos es
inhumano
muchos de estos hechos no fueron
filmados tenemos muertos entre nosotros
y jóvenes que están en la cárcel y hay
heridos graves pedimos a la asociación
de derechos humanos que intervenga para
atender a los heridos y al mismo tiempo
pedimos que no se bajen a países de
google aquí no estamos en seguridad
cambiamos de tema y vamos a portugal la
capital del país lisboa acogió del 27 de
junio al primero de julio una
conferencia internacional sobre el
estado de los océanos según la unión
africana la economía basada en los
espacios marinos es crucial para el
continente
particularmente el sector pesquero
afectado por las actividades de pesca de
multinacionales ajenas al continente
nuestra enviada especial a lisboa marina
colorado habló con representantes
africanos de este sector de la economía
según la unión africana la economía azul
como se le llama a un sistema económico
y social que se base en el uso
sostenible de los océanos y de las zonas
marinas valdrán unos 400 5.000 millones
de dólares para el año 2030 en áfrica
equivalente al producto interno bruto de
egipto por ejemplo el sector de la pesca
es gran parte de esa economía y
representa más del 1 por ciento del pib
de todo el continente durante la
conferencia de los océanos de lisboa los
pescadores artesanales de 27 países
africanos pudieron alzar su voz y pedir
mejoras en las condiciones de un sector
que es extremadamente importante no solo
para la seguridad alimentaria sino
también para la creación de empleo
los recursos son cada vez más escasos y
los barcos extranjeros nos hacen la
competencia sobre todo con los pequeños
peces de aguas cercanas a la superficie
que es el pescado del pueblo y que
asegura una mejor seguridad alimentaria
de la población así que pedimos que este
tipo de pesca sea reservada
exclusivamente para la pesca artesanal
no hay nada que hacer sin nosotros y
tampoco debe hacerse sin otros
pero los océanos no son sólo importantes
para la seguridad alimentaria sino que
son un gran recurso para el turismo así
lo resaltó la directora ejecutiva del
consejo de turismo de kenia país con
anfitrión
el turismo es el tercer mayor
contribuyente al pib de la economía de
en kenia así que todo lo que pueda
entorpecer esa oportunidad o que sea una
amenaza creciente para el negocio del
turismo y la sostenibilidad de este a
futuro es importante para nosotros you
can imagine that is the places y por lo
tanto si el océano es la columna
vertebral de uno de nuestros
contribuyentes clave al pib esta
conferencia es muy importante para
nosotros porque se enfocan las
oportunidades las amenazas los retos que
afectan al océano a su sostenibilidad e
integridad and entering
finalizada la conferencia de los océanos
organizada por portugal y kenny a los
ojos del mundo estarán puestos en el
continente africano de nuevo cuando se
celebre la próxima cumbre sobre el
cambio climático en egipto en noviembre
de este año
más de 61 años después de su muerte
patrice lumumba héroe de la liberación
en el primer jefe de gobierno de la
república democrática del congo fue
enterrado en su país kinshasa la capital
congoleña fue el escenario de una
ceremonia realizada el pasado 30 de
junio una fecha cargada de simbolismo de
dado que coincide con la celebración del
día de la independencia nacional en el
interior del ataúd solo reposaba un
diente del dirigente asesinado que fue
devuelto por bélgica a la familia de
lumumba se trata del único resto que se
conserva del líder asesinado ya que su
cuerpo fue disuelto en ácido y sus
restos nunca fueron encontrados décadas
después fue dado a conocer que este
diente había sido conservado en bélgica
patrice lumumba fue enterrado en este
mausoleo la ceremonia tuvo lugar en
presencia de dos jefes de estado el
presidente de la república democrática
del congo félix y se quede y el
presidente de la república del congo
denis sassu un yeso
el presidente de la rdc en su homenaje
al héroe nacional
vuelve 61 años después bajo el suave sol
de este 30 de junio día sagrado de
nuestra liberación del yugo colonial
unión
nacional ustedes para nosotros
nacionalistas congoleños y para los
progresistas de todo el mundo el símbolo
de la lucha por la libertad la
independencia y la soberanía de los
pueblos el asunto de la república
democrática del congo pasamos a egipto
en la capital el cairo las centenarias y
emblemáticas casas flotantes podrían
desaparecer el gobierno ha ordenado a
sus habitantes a abandonar las lo antes
posible para convertirlas en áreas
comerciales una situación para ellos
incomprensible
estas casas barcos características de la
capital egipcia podrían desaparecer son
objeto de una orden de desalojo por
parte del ejército gobernante que quiere
entregar las a comerciantes los
habitantes están desesperados
vivo aquí en esta casa flotante mi casa
que corre el riesgo de ser demolida en
unos días este barco es mi casa la de
mis hijos y de mis nietos llevo diez
años viviendo aquí en facebook ya se han
quitado algunas casas porque los
habitantes recibieron una orden de
desalojo el 20 de junio con un plazo de
dos semanas sin ninguna oferta de
realojamiento o indemnización podrían
ser sustituidas por cafés hoteles y
restaurantes mucho más rentables
aparentemente para la economía del país
gobernado por militares que ocupan una
posición dominante en los ámbitos del
desarrollo y las infraestructuras
muchos denuncian un sacrificio del
patrimonio
d cómo es posible que casas históricas
hogares de los que viven en el corazón
de la ciudad sean eliminados de forma
tan agresiva y repentina cuando no
causan ninguna molestia al contrario son
respetuosos con el medio ambiente solo
para ser convertidas en cafés y que así
los residentes también denuncian la
falta de consulta como en anteriores
demoliciones cerca del centro de la
ciudad si no se llega a un compromiso
estas casas centenarias acabarán siendo
subastadas la décima parte de su valor
la edición número 14 de la copa africana
de naciones femenina cancelada en 2020
por la crisis sanitaria comenzó el 2 de
julio en marruecos las nigerianas
defensoras del título y 11 veces
vencedoras del campeonato son las
grandes favoritas del torneo aquí un
retrato de las principales protagonistas
de esta competición
así sanz 8 a la de 27 años considerada
una de las mejores delanteras del mundo
y elegida varias veces mejor futbolista
femenina de áfrica senna cani de 26 años
también delantera ha fichado por tigres
convirtiéndose en la primera jugadora
africana que compite en mexico con este
dúo las nigerianas parecen ser
invencibles sin embargo habrá que seguir
de cerca a la camerunesa hallar a chut
de 29 años cuya familia no quería que
jugara al fútbol y quien protagoniza una
exitosa carrera en el inter de milán la
sudafricana te envié el gatland de 20
seis años del atlético de madrid
finalista en la cam 2018 contra nigeria
la capitana zambiana barbra banda de 22
años delantera del shanghai shendi en
china y la joven marroquí estaba a
seguir de 21 años quien juega en la
sampdoria de génova en italia con esta
alineación de élite despedimos la
edición de esta semana gracias por
acompañarnos la información continúa en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]